then 10 years into my career 10 years
after mall rats
suddenly like everything changed
suddenly people had watched it on home
video or on hbo
or for years and i was the one
i always remember that flopped and i
would say that to people i was like oh
my god that movie tech where you know
people go i love mall rats i'd be like
where were you
in 95 we could have used your help it
couldn't have tanked it can't be no way
it's got to be a huge box office success
because i have it on dvd and i'm like
those two things are not necessarily
equitable
so you realize you're the one that
carries around the failure
like you wear you know just like jacob
marley we wear the chains we forge and
like
ain't nobody out there still remembers
that mall rats tank
except me maybe some i'm not even anyone
at universal anymore they're all
gone at this point and
changed so many times so there was a
time i was terrified and then
10 years later and even up till this
moment in time
mall rats is like one of the movie oddly
the movie that almost killed my career
is the one that has kept it
buoyed isn't that something like
stan lee
reading the script from all rats and
captain marvel
with you know was doing his lines out
loud was like everything that to me was
the moment
where i was like you know what like
because i remember like being there when
people were like you shouldn't have done
that
maybe you shouldn't have made that book
of that's the worst thing in the
world to hear right
like oh man second guessing your
artistic statement your statement your
you know um testimony if you will but
like
when stan lee you know was was doing the
line you know trust me true believer
in captain marvel that for me was
graduation day where i'm like
this movie that everyone
left for dead in the goddamn
hot sun and survived and like
you know lives and has this weird
modicum of respect to it and
so
you never know what the thing's gonna be
but i
i do often wonder if i had jumped into
smallville
like when they had written me that fax
what would the career look like today